i'm now going to do one of my least
favorite things to do by hand and that
is to an invert a 3x3 matrix and it can
be useful because you can solve systems
that way but you'll see it's very
computationally intensive and it is
better to be done by a computer and the
only thing that's more painful is doing
a four by four or a four by five matrix
which would or in a four by four or a
five by five matrix which could take all
day and i'd probably definitely make a
careless mistake but let's just take it
step by step
so the first thing i'm going to do this
is my three by three matrix is i'm going
to construct a matrix of minors
so let me construct here
a matrix
matrix
of
miners
and i'm going to draw this really big
right over here because to give
ourselves some real estate and the
matrix of miners what you do is for each
element in this matrix
you cross out the corresponding row the
corresponding column and you replace it
with the determinant of the elements
that are left so what are left when you
get rid of this row in this column the
minor is 1 1 4 5.
so the determinant of 1 1 4 5.
let's keep doing that
this will be replaced i'll let you think
about that first what is this going to
be replaced with
well it's going to replace this row this
column the determinant of two one three
five
determinant of two
one
three
five
let's keep going
let's do
this element it's going to be replaced
with the determinant of
replace the get rid of this row this
column two one three four
two
one
three
four we're a third of the way done at
least with this first stage of it
so for this element right here it's
going to be replaced with its minor
is so we get rid of this row this column
the minor's negative the determinant of
negative 2 2 4 5.
negative 2
2
4
five
then we have
i'm trying to switch up the colors
reasonably this element get rid of the
middle row middle column you're left
with the determinant negative one two
negative one two
3 5
3
5.
now we move on to and i'm really running
out of colors this element right over
here where it's minor is
we'll get rid of this row this column
negative one negative two negative one
negative two
three four
three
four
so let me see that
sorry someone's car alarm started
ringing outside so let me make sure i
didn't lose my focus here don't want to
make any careless mistakes this row this
column negative 1 negative 2 3 4. all
right now let's move over here get rid
of the first column last row you have
negative 2 2 1 one
so we have negative two two
one one
now let's move to this one
this the this the middle column bottom
row you have negative one two two one
so we have negative 1
2
2 1
2 1.
and then we are in the home stretch for
at least the matrix of minors and so we
are looking at this element right over
here get rid of the last column last row
you're left with negative one negative
two
two
one
so the determinant of negative one
negative two
two
one
and from here we just have to evaluate
each of these to get the actual matrix
of minors this is just a representation
of it so let's do that
let's do that so once again we're still
at the stage of getting our matrix of
miners
and actually i don't have to write as
big anymore because now they're going to
have numeric values they're not going to
be these little determinants of 2 by 2s
so what is the determinant over here on
the top left
well it's going to be 1 times 5
minus
1 times 4 1 times 5 minus 4 times 1 so
it's going to be 5 minus 4
which is 1.
what is the determinant over here this
blue determinant
well it's going to be 2 times 5 which is
10 minus 3 times 1. so 10 minus 3 is 7.
what is this determinant on the top
right going to evaluate 2
well you have 2 times 4 is 8 minus 3
times 1 so it's 8 minus 3 which is 5
which is 5.
then we go over here negative 2 times
what is this determinant going to
evaluate to
we have negative 2 times 5 is negative
10
minus 4 times 2 so it's negative 10
minus 8 which is negative 18
negative 18.
then we have
negative 1 times 5 which is negative 5
minus 3 times 2 so it's negative 5 minus
6 which is negative
11. i want to do that in white
negative
negative 11.
what's this determinant going to
evaluate to
we have negative 1 times 4 negative 4
minus negative 6. so that's negative 4
plus 6 which is positive
positive 2. i want to do that in that
so that is
positive 2. we have 3 left
what does this evaluate to
negative 2 times 1 is negative 2
minus 1 times 2. so it's negative 2
minus 2
gets us to negative 4 home stretch now
negative 1 times negative 1
is negative 1
minus 2 times 2 so it's negative 1 minus
4 which is negative five
and then finally
we have negative one times one is
negative one
minus two times negative two so minus
negative four so it's negative 1
minus
negative 4 that's the same thing as
adding a 4. so it's negative 1 plus 4 so
it's going to be a positive 3. so this
right over here is our true matrix of
minors
and from there we can get our co-factor
we can get our cofactor matrix just by
remembering a checkerboard pattern so
our checkerboard pattern tells us
positive negative positive
negative positive negative
positive negative positive it's a little
self-explanatory why it's called a
checkerboard
so if we sign this matrix of minors in
this pattern then we get our cofactor
matrix so let's
set up our cofactor matrix right over
here
so this is our co
factor
cofactor a lot of terminology but
hopefully it's making a little bit of
sense our cofactor matrix we just have
to apply these signs to these values the
to the matrix of minors
so
1 is now going to have applied a
positive sign to it so it's still just
going to be a positive 1.
you're going to have 7 but it's going to
have a negative sign applied to it so
it's going to be a negative 7.
you have a 5 positive 5.
the 5 is already positive you multiply
it times a positive it's going to be a
positive
you have negative 18 but we have to
multiply that times a negative so you
get positive 18
positive 18. you have negative 11
multiply that times a positive one and
so you still have negative 11.
you have
you have positive two multiplied by a
negative one you're going to have
negative two
and you have negative four multiplied by
a positive one you still have negative
four
and then you have negative 5 what is
this going to be in the cofactor matrix
well you take a negative 5 multiply by
negative 1 you have a positive 5.
and then finally you have a positive 3
multiplied by a positive 1 you're still
going to have a positive 3. so we've
gone pretty far in our journey this very
computationally intensive journey one
that i don't necessarily enjoy doing
of finding our inverse by getting to our
cofactor matrix now we just have to take
this determinant multiply this times 1
over the determinant and we're there
we've figured out the inverse of matrix
c